ces villes ont de l'électricité il y a de l'
argent là-bas des jupes courtes Je prendrai un
camion jamais allumé Je n'aime pas regarder
dans les portes d'Ed mais Jax Je peux généralement
trouver quelque chose là-dedans Je peux voler tu
sais que papa est comme si je te disais tu
sais  ce que vous ne voulez pas sa chimie
juste au moment où elle est vraiment conservée quand c'est
vraiment facile comme tout
tout est juste facile mec et vous savez
ce qui est vrai c'est ce qui s'est passé le
premier jour où nous nous sommes réunis
il est tellement parfait c'était très
réconfortant pour tous  d'un coup être dans une
situation avec Tommy Jack et Ted qui
avaient la même chose, vous savez qu'ils avaient juste la
même approche qui était c'est ce que nous
faisons dans la vie
faisons-le professionnellement et ne
nous causons pas d'erreurs et
c'est tellement  beaucoup plus facile quand vous êtes
toujours à 100% ce qui colle ici en premier, c'est
que certainement les bâtons n'étaient certainement pas
le premier groupe qui était bien je
veux dire de moi mais il y a quelque chose à
cela il y avait un groupe dans lequel j'étais mais
juste avant  des bâtons c'était tous mes
copains du lycée que nous
étions toujours dans des groupes différents ensemble et
ce groupe nous nous remettons toujours ensemble
peut-être tous les trois quatre ou cinq ans mais nous nous
remettons toujours ensemble des bâtons
je ne pense pas que c'est une autre histoire
parce que  il y a juste je pense que c'est
quelque chose d'irréparable là alors
je pense que je ne sais pas ce que c'est mais je
pense que de leur part ils n'ont aucune
envie d'avoir une quelconque
relation avec moi pour moi c'est que
je suis gentil  de triste à ce sujet parce que
j'aime que vous sachiez que c'était une grande partie de ma
vie et j'ai en quelque sorte cette
tendance naturelle à vouloir revenir en arrière et en quelque sorte euh
au moins garder la relation ouverte
mais c'est vous savez que ce n'est pas à la hauteur
moi
je vois plus alors oui c'est un peu je suis un peu
triste à ce sujet tu sais je devais juste
non ils m'ont en quelque sorte fait savoir récemment
que je ne suis pas le
bienvenu  mais je ne sais pas quel
est leur raisonnement mais c'est vous savez que c'est
à eux maintenant qu'ils veulent peut-être se réformer
et ensuite vous n'irez pas non nous
en avons parlé et Dennis Dennis est tellement le dernier
album solo a pris plus de temps qu'il ne l'avait
prévu  et Ted, Jack et moi
travaillions déjà ensemble, donc vous savez que
ce genre de choses est devenu très attirant pour
moi parce que nous nous réunissions dans
des bureaux d'avocats et parlions de vous
savez juridique et vous savez des choses qui
n'avaient pas vraiment grand chose à voir avec la musique
et Damn Yankees étaient juste en train de le déchirer
et dans un petit endroit merdique à New
York, nous obtenions gratuitement et
nous ne parlons jamais, nous
n'avons toujours pas été un bureau d'avocat et
donc ça a bien fonctionné et ils  m'a donné
tu sais que le dentiste a dit tu sais vas faire ce que
tu as à faire je comprends que
tu avais fait une sorte de commentaire
quelque part que chacun d'entre vous a
commencé quelque part dans un garage
Dieu merci pour les garages mec nous '  re avec
ce groupe où serait la musique si ce
n'était pas pour les garages sous-sols granges ces
endroits que vous pouvez obtenir gratuitement parce
qu'au début personne ne croit au
début vous n'êtes qu'un gros chieur dans le
cul attachez vos voisins et dans  à la fin
tu sais que tes voisins
vérifient tu sais qu'ils veulent des billets gratuits ils sont
contents aujourd'hui oh ouais pour la porte
c'est souvent un jour de tuerie et pour les parents
aussi tu sais que je suis sûr que chaque parent
d'un musicien a  des histoires d'horreur de
la maison déchirée ou d'
avoir des gens qui marchent sur lui alors qu'ils
sont dans la salle de bain, vous savez et vous
savez que leur maison est totalement perturbée,
mais quand ça marche enfin,
ce sont ces choses qui font de belles
histoires je  avoir une petite fille et je l'ai
encouragée à dire que tout ce dont elle peut
rêver ou souhaiter se réaliser, elle peut
probablement y arriver,
vous savez qu'elle a, elle a une chance de
vraiment aller après quelque chose et je ne vais pas
essayer de la retenir  si elle
veut être dans l'industrie de la musique, une
chose que je sais, c'est que je n'aurai pas grand-chose à dire
à ce sujet, elle le fera avec notre
un ou deux ou pas et je l'ai donc encouragée
à aller après tout ce
qu'elle ressent  bon à propos avez-vous cru
que la philosophie dans les jours avant que vous
ayez conclu un accord et que vous ayez commencé à
y aller avez-vous cru que
si vous vouliez quelque chose d'assez mauvais, cela
pourrait se réaliser
non, ma philosophie est plus rétrospective,
vous savez que je peux regarder en arrière  et voir les
chemins que j'ai choisis mais j'ai vraiment
fait toujours ce que je voulais faire j'étais
un peu un enfant timide et ma guitare
m'a permis d'avoir une liberté totale
et de pouvoir appeler tous les coups alors
et ça aussi  m'a permis dans
des situations sociales d'être en quelque sorte en
charge de tout et je vous savez que je
n'avais pas besoin de penser à quelque chose d'intelligent
pour dire que je pouvais écrire une chanson et que
cela parle pour moi et ainsi de suite
pour moi  c'était c'était une façon d'être
accepté socialement une façon de rencontrer des filles
vous savez et c'était à un âge précoce comme ça donc
j'ai toujours fait ce que je voulais faire
et jamais il n'y a jamais eu de moment dans ma
vie où c'était comme hmm je veux dire  il y
avait pendant le lycée, je le reprends,
c'est qu'ils ont mis beaucoup de pression sur vous,
vous savez au moins au moment où j'ai senti
qu'il y avait beaucoup de pression sur moi pour dire
d'accord, qu'est-ce que tu vas faire quand tu
sortiras de haut  école quel tribunal tu
sais dans quoi tu vas te spécialiser à l'
université je pense je ne
sais pas je suis de retour je suis trop occupé je joue
des concerts le week-end je joue des concerts
alts  pendant la semaine, donc je le
faisais toujours Je pense que si vous avez la chance
d'avoir quelque chose pour lequel vous êtes bon
et que vous appréciez, je pense que vous avez une
très bonne chance de le faire en
même temps, tout le monde n'a pas les pauses
tout de suite, vous savez qu'il y a une certaine
part de vérité dans le dicton, vous savez que
plus je travaille dur, plus j'ai de la chance,
mais en même temps, c'est bien d'être
prêt à sortir, vous savez que vous l'avez,
vous devez quitter le nid que vous avez  pour
quitter la maison, vous devez aller là où se trouvent les choses, vous
ne pouvez pas vous attendre à ce que cela vienne à
vous, vous pourriez avoir de la chance, mais vous devez
être prêt à sortir et
à concourir et si vous le faites une fois,
c'est le  la partie la plus difficile parce que si
vous êtes assez bon pour aller jusqu'au
bout, vous constaterez probablement que
vous faites partie de vos pairs, la
partie la plus difficile est simplement de couper ces liens
et de sortir de
la ville et d'aller là-bas et de chercher
c'est qu'il y a déjà eu un moment avec l'
industrie de la musique de la musique
peut-être que la musique n'a pas eu le meilleur de
vous eh bien je suis juste dans l'
industrie de la musique il y a des connards
là-bas et chaque ligne de travail que j'arrive juste
et il y a honnêtement dans le
dans le monde de la musique, j'ai beaucoup de
gens vraiment sympas, beaucoup de
gens qui travaillent très dur et généralement plus
ils sont gros une fois que vous vous trouvez dans une situation
avec eux où ils réalisent
qu'ils sont en sécurité avec vous, ce sont des gens très gentils avec
qui  travailler avec ça, tu
sais que je ne peux penser qu'à une
poignée peut-être moins que celle des gens
que je pensais vraiment étaient tu sais que tu
pourrais dire publiquement que ces
gens sont des imbéciles le frisson c'est toi nous
ne savons toujours pas ce qui est  va arriver, vous
savez, nous savons qu'ils n'allaient pas tous
avoir des limousines assises
24 heures sur 24, nous savons que nous
n'avons pas besoin de voler en première classe, bizarre, vous
savez, nous pourrions savoir comment venir
ici et avoir  un bon moment et et rendre
cela possible sans trop
s'impliquer sans s'asseoir dans
des réunions d'affaires nous utilisons simplement nos têtes vous savez
nous venons ici pour jouer nous venons
ici nous ne venons pas ici pour être en
vacances ce que nous voulons  faire est de monter sur
scène et de botter le cul à la
fin de la journée et d'essayer de ne pas être trop
fatigué par les choses qui se passent autour de nous, donc
nous le gardons très discret, nous avons été
surpris car à l'époque il
n'y avait pas  vous savez que nous ne
pensions pas que notre musique allait vous savez que MTV
ne jouait aucun type de rock and roll
du tout, donc nous savions que nous ne pouvions pas compter là-dessus
et nous avons donc pensé que nous allons juste
faire  il le libère et voit ce qui se passe,
vous savez et nous ne sortirons pas et nous ne
lutterons pas avec lui, nous n'irons pas là-bas et
jouerons dans des clubs et prierons pour que
quelque chose fonctionne si certaines balises nous
le soutiendrons, mais sinon  nous pouvons simplement
le garder dans la salle de répétition et le faire
quand nous en avons envie et donc cela
a payé nous avons été surpris que les choses se
mettent en place
MTV a commencé à jouer des vidéos rock vous savez
à un moment où cela a vraiment aidé notre
enregistrement notre disque  fait mieux donc nous avons fait
mieux en concert nous nous sommes accrochés avec
le package avec une mauvaise compagnie et cela a
fonctionné
donc c'est pourquoi nous sommes restés coincés avec
ça maintenant nous sommes comme unis à la hanche
avec ces gars vous vous connaissiez
il est passé comme le jeu la dernière
fois il y avait un moment où
Styx jouait Texas Jam en 1983
et Ted Nugent c'est comme un mot que Ted
Nugent jouait avec Sammy Hagar qui
ouvrait pour Styx et nous jouons
que le coton  Bowl dans l'Astrodome
et Sammy était là-bas juste en train de faire exploser
l'état juste une vieille voiture junky et
juste beaucoup de bric-à-brac autour
de la scène et c'était comme un dépotoir et
ils étaient là-bas en train de faire exploser des trucs
et nous avions le tuer  évaluez cette production
qui a été conçue pour être dans les théâtres et
tout d'un coup, c'était dans l'Astrodome,
donc ces petits écrans, je veux dire, ils étaient
un peu minuscules là-dedans, ne
pensant pas à l'homme que je ne veux plus jamais suivre
Ted Nugent  n'est-ce pas ce n'est pas
amusant et vous savez que j'ai eu mon souhait de
descendre et de jouer avec ces gars qui n'étaient
que ce trio de tueurs, il y a un
groupe de quatre musiciens juste des gars funky soul
de vous savez vraiment certains des
meilleurs gars de la région  et je voulais
jouer avec et ils faisaient un
peu d'aide de mes amis Joe Cocker
et moi et je me suis levé et je l'ai chanté et j'étais
vraiment nerveux et dans mon cœur
j'avais cette super performance en cours
mais mon pote  qui a conduit en Floride
avec il était en quelque sorte là-bas, il
allait en quelque sorte venir vous savez et si
quelque chose venait de se casser et et tout d'
un coup je l'ai juste laissé tomber et je me lamentais
mec ça devait avoir paniqué certains de
mes amis, je pourrais tout d'un coup, je viens de
l'ouvrir et de laisser le
truc de l'âme se produire et je n'ai jamais eu
le même sentiment, c'était assez évident
que les choses élevées que nous ferions, nous
savions que le renégat serait probablement
probablement  sois une bonne idée pour moi et
non plus ne me dis pas que tu m'aimes un rock
en Amérique pour Jack et définitivement la
fièvre des griffes du chat pour Ted parfois nous
faisons chacun pour soi nous de temps en temps
à la rigueur ferions du bleu  -collier mais
nous l'avons vraiment limité aux
points forts parce que
nous avons découvert qu'il y a une telle nouvelle
n'a pas vraiment besoin de s'appuyer autant sur
notre passé, vous savez que les Damn Yankees ont
un son qui leur est propre et nous  avoir
notre propre public maintenant, ce qui était un
autre petit avantage de tout
cela, vous savez que nous étions prêts à
sortir, vous savez que nous aimons les points forts de
notre chemin et nous n'avons aucun problème à
le jouer mais il n'y a rien de tel  de nouveaux
airs quand tu allumes la radio et que tu
entends quelque chose comme viens naviguer
où va ton cerveau c'est nostalgique pour
moi tu sais j'essaie de me souvenir des bons
côtés de ça tu sais et c'est
bien c'est de la bonne nostalgie tu sais
parce que si c'était  pas pour cette époque, je
ne serais probablement pas ici en ce moment Jack
Blazes dans notre groupe, tu sais que Ted [ __ ] de
Nugent est ce guitariste dans le groupe,
tu sais, il est parfois difficile de croire
que c'est quelque chose
qui est si médiatisé comme  ça peut
être tellement décontracté et bien que je
ne savais pas à quoi m'attendre quand
Tommy a appelé pour la première fois et a dit que
Nugent arrivait et que nous allions nous
réunir et jam je pensais que ça
allait être amusant mais  ça ne marchera jamais,
vous savez parce que c'est comme le chemin de Tommy
ici et le chemin de Ted ici, mais cela a
très bien fonctionné parce qu'ils
se complétaient et oui, il y a eu un
gel immédiat qui s'est produit et quand
Jack est arrivé deux mois plus tard, il était
le disparu  lien et le tout
juste verrouillé, qu'est-ce que
vous pensez avant d'avoir le
plus en commun
musicalement ou juste tout ce qu'il
contourne bien et les biddies mariés
s'en soucient beaucoup aujourd'hui, je suis si bon pour ça,
oh ouais je  'ai déjà parlé à
Ted oui d'accord eh bien je pense que je pense que le
plus le plus la première chose qui
me vient à l'esprit est que nous avons tous
la même attitude quant à la façon dont nous
nous présentons professionnellement là-bas
il n'y a pas de slackers là-dedans  cette
organisation, il n'y a pas de drogue, il n'y a pas d'
alcool et heureusement, tout le monde
avait cette attitude, donc c'est
vraiment cela qui nous a liés instantanément parce que
nous, vous savez, nous venons de voir que nous
avions tous la même
accumulation pour cela nous  juste vous savez que nous faisons
notre travail et nous l'apprécions et nous nous
amusons plus que quiconque ne devrait être autorisé à en
avoir mais nous vous savez que nous ne
laissons pas les obstacles nous gêner, je
me sens très chanceux que le  les
gars de ce groupe sont comme ça ouais
parce que juste le fait que tu n'as pas
à prendre le relais pour
quelqu'un d'autre que tu connais à cause de
se retrouver dans ces situations
ouais je veux dire c'est génial tu ne pouvais pas demander
un  mieux s'il y a eu des
circonstances où nous serions au milieu
d'une chanson et que je lèverais les yeux,
je lèverais les yeux vers Ted qui serait en train
de jouer à la fièvre des griffes du chat et
je voudrais juste en quelque sorte  pense qu'est-ce que
je fais tu sais parce que j'avais l'habitude d'aller
tous les voir quand j'étais au
lycée et j'étais au premier rang
avec mes poings en l'air comme tout le
monde donc ce n'est pas ce n'est pas un ce n'est pas  une
constante, ce n'est pas comme un truc de type AW
parce que Tommy Jack et Ted m'ont rendu
très confortable d'être dans ce
groupe, ils m'ont fait me sentir comme un égal
depuis le premier jour et il n'y a
jamais eu de truc de piédestal
avec ça  donc pour cette raison, le fait
que je sois le sans nom dans un groupe avec
ces gars célèbres où quelqu'un peut
penser que ce serait probablement très difficile
à faire parce que vous êtes négligé
ou bla bla bla je ne me sens pas comme ça à
tout ça parce qu'ils m'ont fait me sentir comme
un égal donc ça a été génial mais
de temps en temps je lève les yeux et je
ris juste un peu en pensant que
c'est plutôt cool quand le groupe est
sorti pour la première fois il y avait toi  pourrait en quelque sorte
regarder dans la foule et voir bien qu'il y a des
fans de Tommy, vous savez que ce sont des fans de Jack,
ceux-ci doivent être des fans de Ted
et que ce n'était pas surprenant parce que
le groupe n'avait pas vraiment ses propres fans
au début alors que nous progressions et  nous sommes
sur la route depuis 10 10 mois déjà au cours de la
dernière année, nous avons vu ces fans se
mouler et de nouveaux fans sortir et
il y a beaucoup de nouveaux fans de Yankee
qui n'étaient pas des fans de Nugent Sticks ou de Night
Ranger  vous savez que les jeunes filles
ou les adolescents en général que nos
fans de ce groupe n'étaient même pas là
pour être des fans du passé, ils le savaient peut-être
et vous savez peut-être que leurs
frères aînés avaient les disques de ce genre de
choses mais mais c'est  été vraiment
intéressant de voir comment la foule a
changé et nous l'avons vu changer vous
savez au cours de la dernière année, c'est au
point maintenant
que c'est une foule de Damn Yankees
et il y a comme des poches ici et
là vous savez des fans inconditionnels  du
passé, mais ces gens deviennent de
sacrés fans de Yankee, vous savez qu'ils
ont toujours en quelque sorte le tu sais qu'ils
attendent que leur morceau de bâton préféré
arrive, ce qui est bien
quand on considère qu'il y a 15 ans
entre les deux  A et point B ce n'est pas
tu sais que ce n'est pas aussi bizarre mais je veux dire je veux
vraiment dire que je savoure mon travail
j'aime ce que je fais et je sais que j'ai beaucoup
de chance d'être le batteur de ce groupe
et oui je veux dire il y a  il y a une partie
de moi qui pense que je peux prendre du recul
par rapport à ça et le voir et partir c'est
vraiment cool que vous ayez l'
opportunité de jouer avec ces gars et
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait et maintenant c'est ce qu'ils
sont  faire et tu en fais
partie alors oui tu sais que c'est
très spécial pour moi c'est le premier
album sur lequel j'ai jamais joué et c'est 2
millions tu sais donc je pense que c'est
un peu un pas en avant
ouais le premier concert que j'ai jamais eu était en
tournée avec Tommy et c'était vraiment
cool parce que nous étions avec Rush et
nous avons tourné avec eux pendant quatre mois
et nous avons fait toutes les grandes arènes du
pays et je suis littéralement passé de neuf
à cinq  travail de jour à New York pour
faire une tournée d'arène, donc c'était comme si
c'était une gifle totale, donc
c'était un grand pas, puis passer de
cela à tout d'un coup être dans Damn
Yankees et vendre deux millions d'albums
était  un autre très grand saut ça ne s'est pas
produit
bang bang bang il y avait beaucoup de petites
étapes entre les deux et beaucoup d'indécision
et on ne sait jamais si ça va
arriver ou pas alors oui je veux dire c'est c'est
c'était incroyable tu sais que je pourrais  Je ne
demande pas une meilleure position, le fait que
Tommy Jack et Ted sont si faciles à travailler
avec tout le monde s'entend très bien et quand
le groupe est sorti pour la première fois, il y avait beaucoup
de battage médiatique et beaucoup d'attention à cause
de leurs noms et j'étais  a balayé
ça parce que c'était un groupe et
les quatre noms étaient là
alors oui je pense vraiment que j'ai rendu certaines
personnes folles que moi que j'étais celui
qui est entré dans ça pensez-vous à
Ted ce qui vous vient à l'esprit de chasser
vous pouvez  Je ne pense pas à Ted et je ne pense pas à
la chasse, je veux dire que vous ne pouvez vraiment pas vous
en éloigner. La chasse de Ted et la musique de Ted ou
comme ça et selon le jour où vous les
voyez détermineront quels cafés
étaient des enfants qui ne baisent pas, c'est pourquoi je
reçois  wapiti dans le congélateur je veux dire Tommy et
Jack pour moi sont juste
des individus très sincères axés sur la famille qui sont des
musiciens très talentueux et pour cette
raison c'est c'est vraiment facile de s'entendre
avec eux je sens que j'ai
la plus haute récompense pour moi  en ce moment, c'est que
je considère les Damn Yankees comme le
début de ma carrière. J'espère que les Damn
Yankees,
vous savez, continueront pendant 50 ans, mais ce que
je ressens vraiment,
c'est de l'obscurité pour devenir
vous savez un musicien avec vous  je sais avec
certains avec un certain nom dans l'industrie
à cause de Damn Yankees et ouais et
puis et ce genre de récompense est
une combinaison de choses musicalement
professionnelles et et juste en quelque sorte
vous savez même les
relations personnelles que tout le monde a  s'est
formé à cause de tout le temps que nous passons
ensemble, en fait, Tommy Shaw et sa
femme m'ont présenté, ainsi que ma femme, vous savez,
donc la liste s'allonge encore et encore.
un groupe all-star
demain est-ce que je vais recevoir un
appel téléphonique disant que tu n'as pas besoin de venir
aujourd'hui J'avais l'habitude d'y penser mais j'ai en
quelque sorte découvert que j'étais mon
pire ennemi parce que ça n'a jamais
été  vraiment une menace et par mon genre d'
y penser dans le fond de mon esprit,
peut-être que cela m'a rendu encore plus
affamé et que j'ai essayé une charte pour
totalement verrouiller cela, mais ils ne
m'ont jamais donné l'impression qu'ils
n'étaient pas satisfaits de ce qui se passait  sur donc je
me retrouverais à commencer à penser bien
gee
et ensuite je réaliserais une minute
pourquoi même en pensant comme ça ça se
passe bien et je n'ai pas
senti que je n'avais jamais eu l'impression de ne jamais appartenir à ça
comme  Ted t'a fait sortir et essayer de tuer
quoi que ce soit, mais oh ouais nous avons tous deux
lois non écrites
c'est
deux fois bien je veux dire c'est une sorte
de sentiment rassurant je veux dire je n'y ai même jamais
pensé tu sais
quoi pendant que ça se passait je veux dire quand
quand Night Ranger s'est séparé et le groupe
ce que tu sais était comme sur  un déclin et
vous savez quand nous avons rompu, je n'ai jamais
pensé que Jésus, vous savez, je dois à
nouveau entrer dans un groupe qui va vendre
à nouveau 10 millions de disques, vous savez, je veux dire,
je n'y ai jamais pensé de cette façon.  pour entrer dans un
groupe, je vais soit prendre je
vais prendre six mois de congé et aller au
Tahiti et juste traîner parce que je
n'ai pas eu de pause depuis 1981, vous savez
parce que neuf Rangers viennent de tourner et
de tourner et  J'ai fait une tournée alors j'ai pensé que soit
j'allais faire ça, soit j'allais
entrer dans quelque chose tout de suite tu sais je
veux juste être dans un autre groupe c'est
tout parce que je veux juste jouer de la musique
et je veux juste faire du rock and roll  et et
ainsi de suite, ce n'était même pas une chose comme
d'accord maintenant, comment vais-je, comment vais-je
aimer réussir à nouveau ou comment je
vais entrer dans quelque chose qui
se reproduira vraiment tout ce que vous savez
quand quand j'ai cassé Ranger  tout mon
processus de réflexion était mec je veux jouer à nouveau dans un groupe
dans qui je veux être tu sais je
veux être avec un groupe de gars que
personne ne pensera jamais que c'est
autre chose qu'un rock droit et
roll band vous savez et parce que parce
qu'avec Night Ranger, je veux dire, nous avons
commencé comme ce vrai truc de rock and roll, un
vrai coup de pied, ne me dites pas que j'aime faire du
rock en Amérique et puis nous avons eu cette
ballade appelée Sister Christian qui
est devenue comme un  énorme disque dans le pays
et tout, mais c'était une sorte d'épée à double tranchant,
je veux dire à partir de ce moment-là, notre
maison de disques ne nous permettrait de
sortir que des x valides et puis les gens ont eu
l'idée fausse que Night Ranger n'était
rien d'autre qu'un groupe de ballades vous  sais et
et donc j'ai pensé bien tu connais le prochain
groupe dans lequel je suis je veux m'assurer que je suis dans un
groupe que personne ne pensera jamais que c'est
autre chose qu'un groupe de rock and roll et
hoobat mais tu sais Ted ce
maniaque fou  guitariste tu sais je veux dire quand
avec Ted le groupe personne ne pense que c'est
autre chose qu'un groupe de rock and roll donc
ça marche juste parfait je suis
surpris je penserais que toute cette
expérience te battrait juste je veux dire
te fatigue juste comme donner  moi une pause
je dois sortir ici mais ensuite vous vous
retournez et dites que je veux repartir
ouais je ne me fatigue pas je veux dire c'est c'est de la
musique c'est du rock and roll tu sais
c'est de cela qu'il s'agit ce n'est pas comme si
pas comme tu sais oh mec j'ai vraiment
eu une déception je ne fais pas partie de ce genre
de gars qui s'assoit dans les vautres et qui s'apitoient sur eux-mêmes je veux
dire Night Ranger a eu un énorme
succès je suis très fier de toutes les
chansons que j'ai écrites là-dedans  groupe et la musique que
nous avons jouée et puis et les choses que nous avons faites je
veux dire c'était juste une nuit d'homme Ranger
était un groupe qui déchire je veux dire nous avions l'habitude d'
aller sur la route et juste juste déchiqueter
tu sais juste totalement déchiqueter et tuer
et donc je veux dire que je suis vraiment fier de mon
passé et et je dedans et pourtant dans le même
respect, je suis très fier de ce que font les Damn
Yankees, je veux dire parce que nous nous levons juste
là-haut et jouons juste avec un
abandon téméraire absolu
et  c'est encore plus amusant cette fois-ci,
je veux dire, prenez par exemple cette
tournée, nous avons juste décidé de jouer à
l'homme de combat de rue par les pierres, vous savez
parce que parce que j'ai toujours voulu chanter
cette ligne, vous savez ce qu'un garçon po peut faire
au même étage  groupe de rock and roll
qui est la meilleure ligne au monde qui
ait jamais été écrite dans une chanson et je
veux toujours le faire Je ne suis pas Ted un si grand
fan des Stones et Tommy à qui nous disons juste
hé pourquoi ne pas nous vous savez  ce que nous faisons notre
propre version de l'homme de combat de rue
commence le spectacle, donc je veux dire que c'est juste
ce qui est génial avec les Damn Yankees car
nous nous en sortons en faisant tout ce que nous
voulons faire et si nous faisons des choses qui sont
vraiment foutues et folles et  et de vrais
fous et les gens se font remuer, nous
disons juste que c'était Ted qui le faisait tu sais et
nous blâmons tout sur Ted alors il a dit
qu'il vient de dire ouais bien sûr c'était moi
donc c'est parfait c'est parfait c'est une
chose parfaite toi  sais que c'est une situation gagnant-gagnant
nous l'aimons et qui va
se disputer non plus parce qu'ils vont sortir une
gaffe et des échalotes nous vous disons de sortir
une arme à feu et de leur tirer dessus alors quoi que vous
sachiez c'est vous savez qui se dispute avec Ted
bien est là  une chose à laquelle vous
repensez et est-ce que vous manquez quelque chose lors
d'un événement Night Ranger réel est-ce que vous manquez
quelque chose en arrière bien vous savez quand nous avons
commencé notre tournée en juin
1991 1991 avec Damn Yankees nous sommes
allés au Japon et à la porte  deux, nous avons commencé
la tournée là-bas à Tokyo et je vous
savez, un garde de nuit est comme énorme au
Japon, je veux dire que nous avons vraiment réussi et
tout et donc j'étais là-bas et j'étais
comme si j'avais ce genre de ces
sentiments je  j'ai eu des sentiments amusants
j'étais un peu seul et je ne pense pas avoir
jamais dit que j'en avais parlé à Tommy
à propos de ça mais je veux dire que je
devenais vraiment un genre de genre
tu sais comme tu sais souviens-toi de
la nuit  les jours des rangers et nous l'avons fait
et l'avons calé, mais ensuite nous sommes montés sur
scène avec les Yankees et vous savez, nous
l'avons juste déchiré et donc vous
savez que nous avons créé tous nos propres souvenirs
maintenant avec un [ __ ] de Yankees ayant
eu  fait 190 spectacles et vous savez sur
un an maintenant nous en faisons un autre pendant
encore 80 ou 90 spectacles l'été, donc vous
aviez dit que vous étiez fier de votre passé,
mais les comparaisons vous dérangent
constamment, vous avez un an dans votre
record vous  Je suis toujours en tournée, est-ce que ça vous dérange
quand les gens reviennent et disent oh
Night Ranger Night Ranger Ted Nugent
bâton bâtons non ça ne me dérange pas je veux dire aucun
de nous vous savez que nous nous attendons tous à cela
parce que vous savez que nous sommes tous nos fans
vous savez  nous avons des fans de Night Ranger qui
viennent des fans de Styx qui viennent et
des fans de Nugent vous savez je veux dire Tommy et moi
plaisantons toujours parce que ce sont eux nous
venons toujours vous savez nous toujours vous savez que nous
entrons dans la rencontre
c'est le  première question tout le monde
sort ouais ravi de te rencontrer où est Ted
tu sais que Ted arrive tu sais
et c'est juste vraiment c'est vraiment mignon je
veux dire c'est vraiment drôle je le pense mais mais
la bonne chose c'est que tout le monde
y va toujours n'est-ce pas  les egos s'énervent l'
homme je m'en fous je jure devant dieu
honnêtement je m'en fous tu sais je veux
dire je veux dire je veux dire Ted mérite tout ce que
Ted a eu dans sa vie tu sais je veux
dire c'est Ted [ __ ] de Newton tu sais et
Tommy  mérite tout ce qu'il a et je
sais que j'ai aussi fait mes trucs passés
et donc honnêtement, nous n'avons pas de gros
problèmes d'ego avec ce Bane, nous aimons tous
faire ce que nous faisons, nous faisons tous notre
propre truc aussi tu sais Tommy  et j'ai tendance
à beaucoup traîner tu sais parce que nous
écrivons beaucoup de chansons ensemble et nous
avons tendance à avoir beaucoup d'intérêts similaires
tu sais Ted fait son truc et quand nous nous
réunissons en tant que Damn Yankees c'est
juste je veux dire comme pour le  la semaine dernière, nous avons
été chez Ted en train de répéter et il
a un grand lac sur son truc et nous
mec il a un tas de jet skis
là-bas nous détruisons juste sa merde
mec ils sont juste cassés ils sont
déchirés  là-haut, ils battent la merde, c'est
hilarant et il va devoir 10 000
$ à quelqu'un et nous venons de tout gâcher là-
haut.
c'est comme travailler
pour le patron maintenant, vous êtes votre propre
patron et vous pouvez imposer n'importe quelle loi que vous
voulez et tout semble
fonctionner et cela dit n'importe quoi
du point de vue d'un étranger parce que
vous consacrez votre temps, vous vous connaissez vraiment
mettez votre temps et vous avez donné au monde
d'excellents ouais eh bien c'est ce que nous
faisons, nous allons juste et nous vous savez maintenant Tommy
et Ted et je fais les règles et
puis si nous enfreignons nos propres règles, nous rions tous
vous savez que je déteste ça  Je veux dire c'est
juste ouais, nous n'avons tout simplement pas, nous nous amusons juste à
être le [ __ ] de
Yankee qui s'en soucie euh une chose que j'ai trouvée
vraiment mignonne dans la bio que vous
jouiez pendant le tremblement de terre
et la piscine clapotait et  tout ce que
tu décides oh ouais nous sommes quelque chose d'autre
et je l'ai je l'ai j'ai un ranch
dans le nord de la Californie dans la
région viticole et je suis assis au sommet de la
montagne des trucs tu regardes toute la
vallée et puis nous sommes  nous répétons
était dans le genre de zone en bas
et il s'ouvre sur le j'ai une piscine et
des trucs et donc en tant qu'homme juste au moment du
tremblement de terre nous jouons nous
jouions la chanson mec de mauvaise réputation
nous sommes juste  comme le jam et tout ça et
je suis le producteur de synneve cenar Nevo
commence juste à agiter les bras en allant s'arrêter
s'arrêter nous sommes comme ce que vous n'aimez pas
ce refrain ou quelque chose que vous savez et il
était comme oh non tremblement de terre et tout d'un
coup  tu regardes autour de toi et [ __ ] les
amplis bougent et les murs font
ça et je baise nous nous sommes tous arrêtés mec
tu as juste continué à jouer j'ai juste gardé
la chanson mec j'ai du temps et je me lève et
regarde la piscine on ouvre le toboggan
l'homme de la porte vitrée la piscine est comme si j'avais perdu
autant d'eau ma piscine est comme un
raz de marée dans la piscine qui éclabousse et Ted ne peux tout simplement
pas dire tout le temps juste
là-bas juste en train d'aller vous savez juste
scier puis tout d'un coup  15
secondes plus tard, je viens de m'arrêter, puis Ted
s'arrête, regarde, quelque chose se passe, tremblement de naissance,
hein,
il semble temps de recommencer à jouer en solo,
tu sais que la moitié de San Francisco est
détruite et Ted pense qu'il
l'a causé avec ses Marshalls, tu sais que
c'est juste génial, c'était génial, mais c'est
a nous étions là nous étions là pendant le
tremblement de terre wow c'est fou
pour eux et je suis plutôt
content vidéo préférée de Night Ranger pas de
chanson préférée de night manger
vidéo préférée de Damn Yankees chanson préférée de Night Ranger
serait probablement quand tu fermes les
yeux je  aime cette chanson c'est une chanson vraiment cool
qui ne dit pas ne me dis pas que tu
m'aimes ou mon c'est mon qui ne me dis pas
aime moi juste quand je suis bien dans le rock
américain où c'était un bon
qui était  un très bon aussi je n'ai pas
beaucoup de merde bien j'ai écrit presque
toutes ces chansons ha ha je les aime toutes donc
je veux dire ce sont mes préférées je pense ok que diriez-vous d'une
vidéo de Damn
Yankees  assez j'aime
la vidéo assez haute je pense que c'était
vraiment amusant nous sommes allés à la Nouvelle-Orléans pour filmer
ça et c'est vraiment devenu vraiment sale
et sale à la Nouvelle-Orléans et c'est juste que
nous nous sommes tellement amusés
que tout le week-end de tournage  la vidéo
Owen et moi pensons que c'est
ma vidéo préférée j'aime les
flics j'aime le chat au début
ne vous inquiétez pas pour la mort de maman juste eux
vous savez nous pouvons nous avons pensé à toutes
ces choses qu'ils vont juste filmer un
vidéo banale régulière nous allons non
vous n'êtes pas et ceux-ci étaient réels ce sont de
vrais policiers du département de police de la Nouvelle-Orléans
et je veux dire c'était vraiment vraiment
c'était un gaz et je veux dire une histoire
c'était comme trois  dans la matinée et
nous venons de terminer le tournage de cette
partie et Ted et moi retournons à l'
hôtel anakata
ils avaient le capitaine le
service de police de la Nouvelle-Orléans [ __ ] a dit que je
te ramènerai mec nous avons sauté dans la
voiture de l'escouade mec  et il vient juste de 3h00 du matin,
il est juste en train de transporter un homme de cul juste en bas de la
route en passant comme 70 et 80 à travers ces
quartiers résidentiels.
Je suis comme aller beaucoup,
il conduit juste aujourd'hui parce que nous faisons ce que nous
voulons ici et juste mec nous sommes
comme oh je suis content que tu sois de notre côté mec
je veux dire juste comme merde même juste allumer
les lumières et partir  à travers les panneaux d'arrêt
et les lumières, ce n'était pas seulement de la merde oh c'était
vraiment génial
Je continue comme la télé comme total comme total
ce que tu penses qu'il se passe là-bas mec
tu sais vraiment que ces gars gouvernent
cette zone c'est cool d'accord dernière question
ici j'étais  le simple fait de chanter les
entreprises musicales est un peu difficile pour votre
père de famille depuis longtemps et
ce genre de chose et je pensais que
vous n'aviez pas vraiment besoin de refaire ça
d'accord pour rester et partir mais vous êtes
revenu dans ce  et puis quelle est l'
obsession eh bien je veux dire qu'est-ce que je
vais faire d'autre je veux dire je suis un tu sais je joue de la
guitare dans un groupe de rock and roll et
c'est ce que je fais pour c'est ce que je fais je
ne peux pas imaginer tu sais que je peux  Je n'imagine pas
faire autre chose je veux dire ouais c'est
vrai qu'aucun de nous n'avait besoin de faire ça je veux dire
Ted n'avait pas besoin d'être dans un groupe il
n'avait pas besoin d'un gentil tu sais certainement
pas besoin d'être en forme un autre  groupe
soit parce que nous tous, vous savez, nous
nous étions plutôt bien organisés et tout, mais
ce n'est pas à propos de ça, vous savez, je veux dire, c'est
comme si c'était ce que je fais, vous savez, je veux dire,
c'est juste pourquoi je ne pouvais pas imaginer faire
autre chose, je ne peux pas  imaginez que je ne peux pas
imaginer comme vous le savez décider que je ne
voulais plus jouer ou être dans un groupe
je veux dire mec j'aime trop ça tu
sais j'aime chanter j'aime écrire
des chansons j'aime jouer de ma basse  la guitare
devant les gens et donc c'est juste
quelque chose qui est c'est tu sais que c'est dans
ton sang je veux dire c'est dans mon sang je suis
tu sais que je joue
depuis que j'ai huit ans et et mec
une fois que tu attrapes le bug  c'est qu'il n'y a pas
de retour en arrière
tout ce que je suis sûr comme Huey Lewis dans les nouvelles
ou quelque chose que j'étais à la maison les autres bons
amis à moi Michael était parfait depuis
le tout début Tommy l'avait autour
parce qu'il était Michael faisait un
truc solo de Tommy sur ses tournées en solo  et vous
notez que j'ai dit bien ce batteur ce
gars est plutôt bon batteur et eux vous
savez s'il travaille il travaille s'il
obtient le concert tout dépend de lui ce n'est pas
de moi je ne le pousse pas ou quelque chose
comme ça et  donc il est venu le premier
jour où il était là et il ne faisait aucun
doute que quelqu'un d'autre allait être
le batteur mais Michael cartellone II
et il est juste qu'il est juste un monstre je veux dire
tu verras je veux dire juste Plus ce qu'il fait
exactement quoi  lui avons-nous dit de faire et
il ferme la gueule et nous aimons qu'il y ait
assez d'ego dans cette camionnette j'espère que vous
aimez que nous aimons ce
Markel nous aimons que
tant de musiciens qui arrivent au
point de succès vous les avez '  c'est juste
qu'ils sont morts je veux dire s'ils ne sont pas sur
scène tu es inutile je veux dire ils
ne savent pas comment vivre ils ne savent pas
comment faire je ne supporte pas ma femme je
peux '  je ne supporte pas mes enfants je ne peux rien dire
et pourtant vous aimez bien réussi c'est
presque amusant pour vous je ne sais pas c'est
une politique générale d'intolérance
mais j'ai certainement une soif de vivre
qui n'a d'égal que la faim de viande
chiens dans la nuit de 101 d'entre eux je suis
qui mais je creuse mec je veux dire je suis un
mensonge je veux faire du rock and roll et je veux
jouer avec mes enfants et je veux courir
avec les chiens et je  Je veux tuer mon
propre dîner et je veux que tu saches bosser
mon propre marais et je veux changer ma propre
huile et je veux couper mon propre chauffage
voudrais-je prendre ma propre pièce dans mon
magazine et j'ai mon propre camp pour  les enfants
et moi avons les dix années d'
organisation et de publication nées dans le monde que
j'écris avec ma femme et mes copains de chasse
et j'écris également une
chronique bimensuelle pour le magazine offroad comme j'ai besoin
de plus à faire et aussi vers les Damn
Yankees maintenant donc  faire mon émission de radio à
Detroit maintenant, donc je suis le
porte-parole national du programme osé de la police d'État pour
l'éducation à la résistance à la toxicomanie
parce que je suis si bon dans ce domaine et je
le fais vivre et je vais dormir vers 23 heures
tous les soirs à Echo  Park et je meurs comme
un chiot blessé avec une brique dans
le crâne
euh ouais je vis comme ça je veux dire c'est le
monde de Ted et Dieu sait que même la
banlieue où notre ferme était là n'a jamais été le cas
où l'industrie de la musique a eu le
meilleur toi  même pas près rien ne peut prendre
le dessus sur moi je mourrai d'hystérie
dans ma tombe à la
tentative désespérée de certaines personnes de suivre
mon cul blanc aucune industrie de la musique n'a jamais eu
le meilleur de moi parce que je ne suis pas dans le  le
business de la musique je veux dire la création musicale
et je déteste même utiliser le mot business
mais ouais je m'occupe des affaires
mais je ne suis les directives de personne
j'enregistre quand je veux j'enregistre ce que je
veux un disque si je veux et s'il
réussit  il y a des manœuvres alors j'espère qu'ils
vivront parce que je vivrai
Je ne me suis pas plus amusé à jouer
au sommet de ma carrière à guichets fermés à un
demi-million de spectateurs que je ne l'ai fait à me
faufiler sur scène un soir avec
Bosworth et les criminels inadaptés  jouer une
version de femmes honky tonk dans cent
cinquante C club à moitié rempli ça m'est
égal j'ai joué une pièce j'ai appris
à jouer de la guitare à jouer de la guitare
Memphis L trucs et pas à faire X
quantité de musique et  X jours, j'ai
appris à jouer de la guitare, de sorte que lorsque
l'inclinaison s'est tellement manifestée, j'ai attrapé ce
livre et cette grue 1991 toujours ce que je fais
whoa je veux dire, vous savez qu'il n'y a pas de plan défini
car c'est peut-être que vous êtes si réussi
et  tout ce que vous faites c'est parce
que je ne suis jamais motivé par autre chose
que des impulsions intestinales je veux dire eh bien c'est
vraiment un ça peut sembler
transparent comme je le prétends mais je
vous promets qu'il y a une grosse liasse de
substance là je suis allé à la confiture  avec Tommy
Shaw une nuit à New York si ça ne m'avait pas
ému, j'aurais été parti
en quelques instants ça m'aurait ému en quelques
instants là-bas pour les moments tournés en
heures semaines mois années tournées de disques
Damn Yankees
jack blazing Tommy Shawn je je crois
avec Michael cartellone II faire des disques
parce que nous creusons les sons et les
sensations et l'attitude que nous
puons et quand nous ne puons pas les
motivations au niveau de l'intestin, les guitares se font
claquer dans leur étui je sais que je
range la mienne chaque automne parce que je  j'aime les
marais et j'aime les crêtes dans les
montagnes et j'aime me taire
oui les gens c'est Ted Nugent et Dieu
nous aide tous il aime vraiment se taire
hein euh et je disparais et je euh j'ai touché
le monde le vrai le vrai  grognement de
la vie je sors et je chasse avec mon arc
et mes flèches et j'ai touché la terre que
Dieu m'avait initialement prévu de toucher oui je
suis le
guerrier gonzo de combat au corps à corps de la jungle de béton de l'
enfer électronique ouais parce que le rock and roll a besoin de
ça  et il a besoin de rock and roll mais
il y a aussi un endroit où je recharge
mes batteries au-delà de
la capacité d'électrode pour laquelle elles ont été
conçues parce que je me connecte à une
existence paisible dans le monde de la chasse
qui défie la morve et le sang de
l'homme moderne et c'est cool donc  Je suis cool
tes adjectifs idiot eh bien tu l'aimes
ma toute signifie la même personne au
lycée au lycée tu dois réaliser
mec le rock and roll m'a mordu les
fesses vers 1954-55 Dick Dale sur les
del-tones The Ventures Lonnie  Mack Duane
Eddy, vous connaissez tous ces gars, je veux dire pas
Les Paul, n'avait inventé la
guitare électrique que peu de temps après la
révolution industrielle, puis la télévision,
puis la semaine suivante, Ted est né, alors
j'ai sauté sur le premier wagon de marchandises qui
se dirigeait n'importe où.  il se trouve que je me
dirigeais vers le rock and roll j'ai été ému par
le twang j'étais poussé par tout ce qui
nous pousse tous à aimer les rythmes du
rock and roll je n'y ai pas pensé
parce que cela aurait éliminé les
sensations au maximum dont
j'ai envie  sensations au maximum je
cultive nourrir découvre et dans des
sensations de bosse que leur maximum donc
Ted à l'école maternelle au lycée
au-delà de l'école a toujours été la
même créature évidemment à différents
niveaux de conscience à l'âge tendre de
42 personnes personne ne sort de  Tu es vivant,
je suis assez conscient de ce qui se passe
autour de moi en chantant quand tu as dit que toi
quand tu es entré en jeu avec Tommy, c'était
quelque chose qui t'a vraiment ému
et je chante les aigus et ton aigu
les aigus de ta vie ont eu  ont
été si élevés y a-t-il quelque chose de ton
passé qui te manque non non parce que je
vais le faire ce soir
ouais la partie préférée de mon passé existe
au moment où nous parlons euh non je ne manque rien de tout
ça mon dieu j'ai vécu les dix
-homme de la vie d'un an ai-je vécu l'homme de la vie de douze ans ai-je
eu mes coups de langue à 14 ans et
je ne l'aimais pas non j'ai vraiment eu
de la chance que mes parents étaient cool ma mère était
un peu une sainte  trop saint parfois et mon
père était un disciplinaire qui m'aimait
également un peu trop disciplinaire
parfois mais j'aime ces extrêmes tu
sais j'aime mon café très chaud j'aime mes
hivers avec de la neige jusqu'aux aisselles et un
vent du nord-ouest qui me bottait le cul je
comme cette partie de la vie, mes
choses préférées dans la vie sont le temps extrême le temps
extrêmement calme le temps extrêmement bruyant
tu vois ce que je veux dire j'aime l'
électricité mec je veux la secousse si je
veux le silence tu sais je veux dire et c'est
comme ça que j'ai toujours poursuivi les choses je  je ne
sais pas pourquoi à part le fait que je n'ai
jamais pris de drogue je n'ai jamais touché une
cigarette ou bu un verre donc mes
sens divins ne fonctionnent pas de
manière optimale donc mon
dépistage mon processus de dépistage de l'intelligence
fonctionne vraiment  bon et ça ne
laisse pas entrer de conneries et s'il ne
laisse pas entrer ce brouillard alors je ne manque pas grand chose
ouais et il y a tellement de choses là-bas euh
c'est tellement à la fin de la journée juste la
fin de ta journée le  les choses auxquelles vous
croyez le plus les
choses les plus pertinentes pour vous en ce
moment aujourd'hui
comme toujours les gens les gens ma femme
Shimane ma fille star fille Sasha
fils Toby fils Rocco les gens dans ma vie
principalement le clan Nugent et puis il
s'étend à mon  mes copains de chasse et mes
copains de rock and roll et mes
copains de police et mes copains d'entreprise et mes
copains mécaniciens et mes copains soudeurs
et mes copains en minijupe et vous savez que ce sont
les gens et juste derrière les
gens se trouvent les animaux certains d'entre eux
saignent un peu  l'un dans l'autre et l'homme je veux dire
saigner se fondre l'un dans l'autre parce que ma
vie tourne autour des créatures de la faune
l'état des
marais sauvages et des collines d'Oak Ridges l'
état de cet environnement cet
habitat est un baromètre par lequel je juge
la qualité de mon existence quotidienne oui
Je suis à Omaha
oui je serai à LA oui je serai à
l'écrasement des chutes du Dakota du Sud oui je
serai à Wango Tango Brésil et toutes
les zones de guerre électronique de la Terre mais
pour chaque heure que je passe dans les
zones de combat de  rock and roll
Je passe autant de temps, sinon plus, avec
un cerf qui arrive et un orignal qui broute et un
aigle qui
s'envole et un rat musqué un chomp et un chien qui hurle et une venaison un gorille
Je veux dire, c'est ce
que ma vie à la fin de la journée, je
pense que chasser les poissons dans ma vie, c'est
avec ces gars ici, je sais que
tout le monde a
vécu ça, tout est là si les choses changent
beaucoup depuis les jours ted nugent quand vous
avait le pantalon blanc serré euh
tu sais ce jour-là, les choses ont tellement changé par
rapport aux gars avec qui tu es maintenant et
dans les situations aussi à l'époque je ne
pense pas que je sois un optimiste désespéré quand j'ai
eu le pic de mon  Carrière des années 70 en tant
qu'artiste solo et j'utilise le mot pic pour
identifier un moment où le public a
identifié les ventes de disques et la notoriété de
mes activités parce que le pic de ma
carrière solo est en ce moment c'est le
pic de tout et je veux dire que je
aura assez de bande pour vous en parler
mais sachez que les choses n'ont pas changé je
pense Rob de Lagrange et cliff Davies
et et Derek st.  Holmes était dévoué
à ce que nous faisions à l'époque, ils
sont des êtres humains Je suis un être humain J'ai
fait des erreurs
Je savoure ces erreurs car j'espère qu'ils
ont savouré ces erreurs car
alors vous pouvez continuer et j'espère ne pas
les refaire je  Je suis avec un tas de gars
en ce moment Tommy Shaw Jack lames Michael
cartellone Ian la nouvelle Julie nous sommes
dévoués à ce que nous faisons nous attrapons ces
outils et nous creusons profondément et nous laissons
nos
sourds sortir la même chose 58 la même chose
68 la même chose  78 même chose dans 88 même
chose 98 promesse donc il n'y a pas de
différenciation autre que le fait qu'à
chaque heure de ma vie je
maîtrise mieux cette heure par rapport aux
heures précédentes en prévision des
heures à venir tu sais je veux dire je  Je ne suis pas un
penseur profond, mais je sens certainement le
vent souffler et je m'adapte en conséquence si je suis
si motivé, donc je suis un
gars utilitaire, je ferai de mon mieux
comme je le fais en ce moment avec vous pour
obtenir  au fond de ces questions
et ce que je pense est une enquête sur ce qui
fait vibrer cette version du rock and roll
américain parce que ça me fascine je le
fais tout le temps et je suis
juste fasciné par ma vie ouais et je
pense  qu'il y a des gens là-bas
qui vont sinon fascinés du
moins intrigués vous apprenez ce qu'il
est vraiment à propos de n'importe quelle moitié je ne comprends pas vraiment
que bon et vous ne le ferez jamais
ventre d'un homme de Sal infesté de tiques
qui n'est pas bon ce n'est pas une jolie
image mais Dieu sait qu'ils l'ont peinte
j'ai eu des avocats j'ai eu des managers
j'ai eu des comptables qui sont des
bâtards démoniaques immoraux et parce que je suis tellement
enthousiaste et je suis  si optimiste et
je penserai le meilleur de vous au
moment même où vous me giflerez dans le baiser
qui vous trottera dans une
flaque palpitante d'humains pas dans les cheveux mais jusqu'à
ce moment je vous ferai confiance et je
vous aimerai peut-être aimer  jusqu'au
moment même où vous insistez sur le fait que je
ne devrais pas et à cause de cette confiance
digne de ma part, j'ai été
chevauché et monté dur aujourd'hui Je ne peux pas
être chevauché et monté dur J'ai un
mécanisme de défense qui est imbibé d'urine
taureau infesté de fil de fer barbelé fouettant de l'
enfer kamikaze vous ne pouvez pas entrer dans la
zone barrière du mécanisme de défense de Ted J'aime
ma vie Je veux roter Rocco Je
veux emmener Toby à la chasse au canard Je veux
même prendre une étoile et tirer sur Sacha shopping
aïe aïe  ça fait mal,
je déteste ces mots mais je veux faire ça
et si tu lèves un doigt pour interférer
avec mon expérience des prochains instants, je
te prendrai la vie, arrache-le de ta poitrine
et enfonce-le dans ton cul si profondément que tu
ne le sauras même pas  qu'est-ce qui t'a frappé, serre-moi
la main et donne-moi un sourire et je te serre dans
mes bras et bave partout avec une réaction positive indique que tu veux me gêner ou me faire du mal et je
te transe et te transforme en une partie du
paysage
mon amour  est sans fin ma capacité à
détester n'est pas assez
hé donc tous les jeunes qui
s'efforcent de vendre des chaussures jouent au rock
and roll ou récupèrent des balles de golf de la
couverture rugueuse ton cul ne compte jamais sur la confiance
dis d'accord je te fais confiance maintenant écrivons-le
et je demanderai à quelqu'un de l'examiner
et de vraiment l'analyser, vous devez faire ce que
Dieu vous aide à ne pas laisser cette
froideur analytique entacher le «pas de péché
dans l'irrévérence» de votre rock and sling
and roll ce n'est pas un moyen facile à
équilibrer mais ça peut être  fait,
regardez-moi, je sais que vous avez
déjà décrit cela dans des journaux, mais le
nom Damn Yankees,
je ne les distille pas simplement pour les meilleures
choses de la vie, ces [ __ ] de minijupes, par
exemple, ces [ __ ] de talons hauts,
ces [ __ ] de guitares, ces [ __ ] d'amplificateurs,
ces [ __ ] de minijupes.  lumières ces fichus batteurs
ces maudites attitudes sont toutes mes
choses préférées
quand nous avons commencé à brouiller nous ressemblions à
un tas de vis semi-caucasiens de Motown Street se
lançant des boogie woogie honky-tonk les
uns aux autres dans la nuit et nous
semblions très américains c'était une époque
où nous  étaient dans d'autres pays
pour protéger ce que je pense être juste,
défendre ce que je pense être juste,
essayer d'empêcher des innocents d'
être blessés par des personnes qui étaient mauvaises et
ces mauvaises personnes nous appelaient Yankees
en fait, ils nous enregistrent, [ __ ] de Yankees maintenant,
ne le faites pas  Je sais pour toi mais je suis fier d'être
un [ __ ] de Yankee et c'est comme ça que notre musique
sonnait